un événement dominent l'actualité de ce
jeudi
humiliés les morts pour terroriser les
vivants s'attaquer à la mémoire et aux
souvenirs et tuer les gens une deuxième
fois
c'est véritablement le choc ce soit en
france après la profanation de tombes
juives au cimetière de carpentras un
acte sans précédent on a brisé des
pierres ont la même exhumer des corps
acte barbare qui n'a pas été revendiqué
sur place les policiers n'ont
pratiquement trouvé aucune trace et pas
d'inscription les réactions sont
unanimes pour condamner beaucoup
évoquent un climat actuel qui incite à
de tels actes de haine nous allons y
revenir d'abord l'effet commentaires
jean marc pitte images de nos équipes de
reportage c'est en venant se recueillir
sur les tombes de leurs morts que des
habitants de carpentras ont découvert
l'horreur dans le cimetière israélite de
cette commune
le cadavre d'un homme récemment inhumé
avait été déterré et empalé sur un pied
de parasol une trentaine d'autres tombes
ont également été profanées marbre brisé
socle soulevée mais apparemment aucune
inscription antisémite
les parents des occupants de ce
cimetière sont aussitôt accouru pour
constater le sinistre dans leur bouche
la consternation c'est plus facile ça
t'as qu'à voir ses spectaculaires disant
certain temps ce sont des gens et ce
sont des débiles mentaux s'attaquait
démons je vais vous dire une chose il
faut être vraiment bas sur terre et ces
gens là j'ai oublié les choses changent
vraiment y avait une justice
il a pris d'ouvrir il devrait repasser
les morts
pierre joxe le ministre de l'intérieur
en visite à nîmes a tenu à réagir
avant même de se rendre sur place nous
pensions que les abominations assiste
tout simplement d abomination qui sont
des crimes contre l'humanité ne pouvait
pas se produire dans notre pays
hélas elles viennent de se produire à
l'égard de mort à l'égard d' dépouille
mortelle pas seulement à l'égard de
tombeaux de tels actes de profanation
barbares criminel aux yeux de ce que
l'humanité a de plus spécifique qui est
le respect de la personne humaine
demande une condamnation solennelle et
indignés qui s'expriment rage on susurre
à travers la france dans les heures qui
viennent
dans la communauté juive de carpentras
l'une des plus anciennes de france on ne
souffre guère de l'antisémitisme
on n'y a d'autant plus de mal à
comprendre cet acte ce soir il n'a
toujours pas été revendiqué madame
monsieur bonsoir à carpentras dans le
vaucluse
on ne comprend pas on ne comprend pas
ceux des inconnus qui ont profané le
cimetière juif dans cette ville vit une
communauté juive depuis le xiiie siècle
elle est même cité historique du
judaïsme français cette communauté
parfaitement intégré et jamais il n'ya
eu d'incidents dans la ville ont dit ce
soir
incroyable absurde dégueulasse il n'y a
pas de mots au total ce sont plus de 30
tombes qui ont été saccagés pierre joxe
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
immédiatement rendu sur place pour
dénoncer une abomination raciste marcel
trillât un acharnement morbide
le corps d'un homme de 81 ans décédé il
ya quinze jours
exhumé de sa tombe arraché à son
cercueil et empalé sur un manche de
parasols les mots semblent dérisoires
pour qualifier cet acte découvert par
deux femmes qui traversait ce matin le
carré juif du cimetière de carpentras
trente trois autres tombes israélites
ont été plus ou moins endommagé les
profanateurs ont sans doute agi dans la
nuit de mercredi à jeudi
les enquêteurs ont relevé les traces de
chaussures d'au moins quatre personnes
le ministre de l'intérieur pierre joxe
qui se trouvaient dans la région pour y
présenter son plan anti incendie s'est
rendu dans l'après-midi à carpentras
pour témoigner aux membres de la
communauté juive l'indignation du
gouvernement
de tels actes de profanation barbares
criminel aux yeux de ce que l'humanité a
de plus spécifique qui est le respect de
la personne humaine demande une
condamnation solennelle et indignés qui
s'exprimera j'en suis sûr à travers la
france dans les heures qui viennent dans
la nuit de lundi à mardi déjà des
inscriptions antisémites avaient été
tracés sur les façades de plusieurs
magasins d'avignon you de raul les juifs
dehors les mêmes mots camirand berg en
madame monsieur bonsoir il ya
aujourd'hui un sentiment d'accablement
que traduisent les réactions venues des
hommes politiques bien sûr mais aussi de
tout ce dignitaire religieux ou simples
citoyens qu'une caméra aucun ni trop à
écouter à carpentras wire accablement
devant la profanation du cimetière juif
de carpentras et face à cet
antisémitisme parfois banalisée dans la
société française la classe politique se
retrouve dans le consensus de
l'indignation
la condamnation est unanimement partagée
sur place il y à l'émotion des familles
et la succession ininterrompue des
officiels patrice volet jean françois
gervais
[Musique]
or
le champ des familles juives pour
pleurer les morts d'auge vite comme si
carpentras avait remonté le temps cet
après midi pour témoigner de leur
solidarité
pierre mauroy françois léotard jean
claude bodin jack lang
harlem désir les mêmes mots la honte
l'horreur l'inquiétude familles
meurtries celle de maurice benassaya sa
mère sa femme sont enterrés ici c'était
leur havre de paix la révolte monte face
à la lâcheté anonyme et toujours la
crainte de l'oubli cette catastrophe
sera jamais une ville remplie
d'histoires vive qu'au cap en train puis
subir qu'on puisse profané son histoire
est par contre a été un exemple pour le
judaïsme français pour le judaïsme
européen il faut que tous les jeunes
chenilles pour lutter contre l'ignorance
contre un et dix ans 180 contre mon
ignorance
il luttera en même temps contre les
médisances contre calomnie contre la
violence et comprenne qu'elle soit une
haine gratuite ou une haine raciale
mais qui pourra ignorer ne plus se
souvenir que cet homme a été sorti de
son tombeau en palais sur un pieu une
seconde mort son épouse ne l'acceptent
pas pour moi il est brisé
déjà que j'ai perdu mon mari est à
présent on n'avait pas vu naître l'idée
ça c'est si les cendres ne pas léser
personne mais eni estime le jeune et
qu'elle était pressée des mots notres
quelques pas et il a choisi de rester
seul face à sa douleur
ce soir au cimetière juif de carpentras
reste quelques fleurs et une immense
indignation
jacques chirac
dhr à la synagogue de la rue en selle à
neuilly sur seine cet engagement
particulier des principaux leaders
politiques français montrent que cette
affaire les mobilise dans l'indignation
de la droite à la gauche
on semble choqué par ce qui s'est passé
hier est parce que cette profanation
révèle de la société française de
l'intolérance dans notre pays depuis une
dizaine d'année oblige tous les uns
politiques à s'interroger sur leur
propre responsabilité
ont-ils toujours fait tout ce qui était
nécessaire pour empêcher le
développement de ce fléau
ce n'est pas aujourd'hui que
j'apporterai une réponse n'est pas le
moment et je ferai à ce sujet des
commentaires et des propositions et
d'autre part je veux dire que toutes les
françaises tous les français et je pense
plus particulièrement aux jeunes qui
font la société de demain doivent se
considérer comme d'abord obliger à une
grande vigilance mais aussi comme en
charge du retour nécessaire à l'esprit
de tolérance à l'esprit de fraternité
sans lesquels il n'y a pas de paix
civile
il n'y a pas de démocratie au delà de la
condamnation qui je l'espère après un
jour les coupables lorsque la justice
aura pu se saisir 2 et à la condamnation
a porté sur tout ce qui contribue à ce
climat de haine qui il y contribue en
particulier par des déclarations
racistes antisémites d'intolérance et
qui crée une banalisation de quelque
chose qu'on ne doit plus voir dans le
monde
on ne veut plus voir en france nous
avons connu hélas pendant la guerre à
une époque où il y avait même des lois
anti juives
nous voulons plus voir ça ni dans la loi
ni dans la politique ni dans la
réalité de notre pays dans le monde et
pour cela il faut combattre le racisme
et ceux qui expriment des idées qui
conduisent à de belles âmes carpentras
ce n'est pas la première fois ces dix
dernières années plusieurs cimetières
juifs ont été profanées et on trouve
souvent sur des façades dans toute la
france des graffitis qui disent
faurisson à raison celui qui nie
l'existence des chambres à gaz ou encore
les juifs dehors
anne consigny décembre 83 habits chaîne
dans le bas-rhin 40 tombe renversé dans
le cimetière israélite le bas-rhin
lederer affirme avoir vu les hauteurs de
jeunes vandales dit il une semaine avant
le même cimetière avait déjà été
saccagés problème actuel est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus ça vous n'avez la
différence ou de la cazine le quasi
manque de réaction des gens devant
quelque forme de brutalité qui peut ce
qui peut s'exercer
aucune réaction n'aura permis en tout
cas d'éviter un scénario semblable se
reproduise un an plus tard à nice
soixante quatre tombes détruites à coups
de masse cette fois les auteurs viennent
de la mouvance d'extrême droite en 88
la série continue en alsace en avril à
weiterswiller dans le bas rhin
90 tomes sont renversés dans le
cimetière israélite trois adolescents
seront présentés au juge pour enfants de
strasbourg un mois après c'est le
cimetière de sarre union pour le même
département qui est touché ici c'est la
deuxième fois en deux ans c'est urgent
d'antisémitisme qui se remet en marche
qu'on fait parce que pour d'autres
encore l'an dernier dans le pas de
calais des inscriptions nazies dans un
cimetière saccagé deux jeunes gens
avouent ils se réclament de l'idéologie
extrémiste des skinheads dans l'est
le midi les hauts-de-seine où ailleurs
cette semaine encore à wissembourg
la liste des cimetières profanés est
longue mais jamais on avait atteint
l'horreur découverte hier à carpentras
alors pourquoi carpentras sans doute une
cible symbole dans une région où
l'établissement des juifs remonte aux
premiers siècles depuis leur présence y
est permanente
la ville fut même à un moment donné
son histoire baptisé la capitale des
juifs du pape
l'histoire avec isabelle staes place de
la juiverie à carpentras la plus
ancienne synagogue de france
un monument historique édifié au 14e
siècle
aujourd'hui symbole de la continuité
juillet ici la communauté a toujours
pratiquer son culte en toute liberté ses
racines dans la région vont probablement
au premier siècle avant jésus-christ
mais c'est surtout au 14e le trouve à
carpentras son havre de paix persécuté à
cette époque mais dont les juifs n'ont
pas le droit de vivre en france mais le
comtat venaissin on carpentras et la
capitale est placé sous la protection
papaye celle 8 du pape trouve alors ici
une tranquillité toute relative s'ils
ont le droit de pratiquer leur culte
ils ne peuvent posséder des immeubles
des terres six à sept cents familles
sont regroupés dans des ghettos des
ghettos qui deviennent de véritables
centres culturels carpentras est alors
baptisé la jérusalem du comtat venaissin
après la révolution les juifs retrouvent
leurs droits de citoyens et se
dispersent à travers la france la
communauté se reconstruit avec l'arrivée
des juifs d'afrique du nord une centaine
de faits ni aujourd'hui mais pour tous
carpentras est une terre d'asile
nombreux sont les descendants des juifs
du pape qui choisissent d'être enterré
ici donc ce cimetière
aujourd'hui pour fanny voilà monsieur
van soir trois jours après la
profanation du cimetière juif de
carpentras s'est déroulé ce matin sur
les lieux même une cérémonie empreinte
d'une très grande dignité
le grand rabbin de france joseph sitruk
a voulu dans son discours d'une certaine
façon ramener à la raison ne laissons
pas dire n'importe quoi at il affirmé
isolons ceux qui sont antisémites et il
a conclu en accordant son pardon à ceux
là même qui ont perpétré cet acte
criminel
pardon à leur insu a dit le grand rabbin
car ces hommes ont montré les limites de
leur impuissance et leur incapacité à
vivre avec les autres reporters patrice
bellet jean-françois changé
silence et recueillement carpentras
ville morte pour un quart d'heure ce
matin comme associé à la douleur à la
prière de la communauté juive au
cimetière se pressait une foule jamais
vue ici plus de dix mille personnes
hommage et dignité une matinée d'émotion
pas toujours contenu trop de souvenirs
trop de révolte pour se taire
je n'ai jamais parlé vous savez ce que
c'est logique il faut qu'on sache que
c'est gauche vite tout brûler tout cramé
alors il faut plus jamais ça disons plus
jamais grâce ici ma b qu'on lit
la vengeance ou le pardon le grand ravin
sitruk a choisi au nom du peuple juif
dans un texte d'hommage à félix germes
ont exhumé de son caveau est violente et
cette semaine nous venons te demander
pardon au nom de la communauté juive au
nom de la communauté nationale au nom de
l'humanité et au nom de tes agresseurs
qu'il soit et c'est peut-être leur plus
grande peine
associé à leur insu à ce pardon
ce qui nous importe c'est que la france
démocratiques d'aujourd'hui comprennent
qu'il ne faut plus laisser faire que la
grandeur d'une démocratie ne se définit
pas par la beauté de ses principes mais
par son obsédante quête de vérité
[Musique]
un jeu
l'espérance est un trésor
invité de notre jour
monsieur robert badinter monsieur
badinter vous n'avez pas encore parlé
sur toutes ces affaires
vous êtes ce soir ici au titre de
spécialiste en tout cas d'un décret d'un
écrivain d'un homme qui a beaucoup écrit
sur ces problèmes de la communauté juive
en france et sur les problèmes du
judaïsme
ce matin on a entendu deux discours
celui du grand rabbin qui disait
justement ne disons pas n'importe quoi
sur ces affaires gardons la raison on a
entendu aussi aujourd'hui madame simone
veil qui disait je ne veux montrer
personne du doigt avant de savoir ce qui
s'est exactement passé qui sont les
criminels
est ce que vous pensez vous qu'il faut
globalisé comme l'ont fait certains pour
dire qu'il ya vraiment eu une montée du
de de l'antisémitisme en france et puis
du racisme aussi je crois d'abord que le
grand rabbin le raison il faut raison
garder et par exemple ce que nous avons
vu tout à l'heure
ces violences commises par ces jeunes
juifs et bien je verrai prouve
absolument et je considère qu'ils ne
nuisent à la cause qu'il croit servir
raison garder il faut quand même prendre
la mesure de ce qui s'est passé
indiscutablement une escalade n'est ce
pas quand on voit des actes de cette
nature il faut bien mesurer la démarche
on se rêve ni je parle des auteurs de
ces sections abominable se réunissent
ils réfléchissent ils préparent leur
horrible mise en scène ils réunissent
les instruments ils partent la nuit ils
ouvrent les tombeaux il casse le
cercueil ils sortent les grappes
je m'arrête là mais réfléchissez à tous
ces actes commis les uns après les
autres de 100 francs et comment ne pas
se dire ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
ça où s'arrêteront ils
donc il est certain qu'on est en
présence d'un racisme à l'état pur il
est certain que même si vous êtes là
devant un acte inqualifiable
on ne doit pas généraliser oui je le dis
très clairement
très fortement pas une seconde on ne
voit pas de globaliser on ne doit pas
viser trop de gens à la foi du croyant
encore plus direct disons le très
clairement la france n'est pas un pays
antisémite l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa
loi sa place en france mais il y a dix
antisémites et des racistes en france et
nous avons vu là quelques alors face à
ce problème que peut-on faire est-ce que
vous pensez que il est nécessaire de
légiférer de faire des lois ou bien à
elle bien ça ne servira à rien ça peut
même avoir là aussi des effets pervers
non c'est pas moi qui via jamais que les
lois on peut avoir des effets pervers
non et simplement je veux bien marquer
d'une part que l'état de droit en lui
même ne peut pas être l'état de
faiblesse je veux dire par là qu'il faut
appliquer fermement la loi mais que dans
des problèmes comme celui là le vrai
débat la vraie question elle s'inscrit
dans le coeur dans les consciences et ce
dont il s'agit essentiellement de demain
une manifestation il faut y aller il
faut qu'on voie le maximum de gens unis
dans leur refus de ce racisme qui qui
risquent de déshonorer la france est aux
yeux de l'étranger aussi
mais au delà c'est le travail
d'éducation
c'est la quête obscur constante de la
vérité c'est le courage de dire la
vérité celle au courage de rappeler qu'
il y a eu des crimes contre l'humanité
et qu'on a tué des femmes des hommes des
enfants rappelez vous les enfants
d'izieu simplement parce qu'ils étaient
juifs
imaginez simplement parce qu'ils étaient
juifs il devait mourir de la même façon
qu'on est allé sortir ce corps pourquoi
de cette terre de provence parce qu'il
était juif et là vous touchez du doigt
la réalité insupportable du racisme et
qu'il faut combattre je suis content que
il y est le tout pas là donc pour les
éléments nouveaux premières réactions
celle de jean kahn le président du
conseil représentatif des institutions
juives de france le crif écouter ce
qu'il a dit à strasbourg à stefanelli
sur ces nouveaux éléments
vous ne m'appartient pas de nous
prononcer sur le fait de savoir si le
corps juge herman a été en panne ou mme
il est suffisamment odieux constater que
cadavres au rhum et été exhumés et que
j'en ai estimé devoir couvrir son corps
d'une étoile tahri qui a été prélevé sur
le monument funéraire de ce cimetière
je crois que ce qui compte c'est que
ceci a eu lieu et que ce ne le gardez
insiste de l'acte a été ta vie par
conséquent tout le reste sera une
question de recherche de la vérité va je
répète je fais confiance aux autorités
notre vie
quoi qu'il en soit des éléments nouveaux
bien sûr ne change en rien la gravité de
ce crime
seulement cela amène tout de même à se
poser quelques questions
marcel trillât un haut-le-coeur
collective provoquée par des faits
spectaculaires 30 capes tombes
israélites profane et un cadavres
exhumés et ce mot terrible empalé un mot
charge et d'angoissé qui ramène à la
surface les horreurs des supplices du
moyen âge l' enquête que nous avons
menée à carpentras et que confirment les
propos du procureur général de nîmes
nous permet donc aujourd'hui d'affirmer
que le mot empalé ne correspondait pas
tout à fait à la réalité des faits
l'horreur est la même le geste
innommable
mais il s'agirait plus exactement d'une
mise en scène macabre d'un acte
d'injures comme il ya des mots d'injures
le piquet n'étaient pas enfoncés dans le
corps mais avait été placé dans la
position de lampes allemands comme pour
insulter la mémoire de monsieur germon
et par personnes interposées
toute la communauté juive nous sommes
les premiers a déploré d'avoir à étaler
ainsi des détails aussi morbide mais
nous nous devons ce soir de poser
solennellement plusieurs questions aux
fonctionnaires de la police judiciaire
au magistrat en charge de l enquête et
au ministre de l'intérieur le mot
empalement ayant été employé à tort dans
l'émotion des premiers moments pourquoi
les enquêteurs n'ont ils pas rectifier
leur premier communiqué lorsqu'ils ont
eu connaissance des faits exa pourquoi
quelques heures à peine après la
découverte de la profanation le ministre
de l'intérieur at il ordonné le black
out total
non seulement sur l' enquête ce qui est
légitime mais aussi sur la description
véridique des faits constatés
tu es par les policiers les magistrats
et le médecin légiste
dans le même temps où les autorités
inciter à juste titre les français à se
mobiliser
elle ne les jugeait pas digne d'être
informés précisément est complètement
sur la réalité de l'événement
à la lumière des dernières révélations
la révolte collective provoquée par la
profanation de carpentras demeure
parfaitement justifiée mais on ne peut à
la fois faire appel à la responsabilité
des citoyens aient refusé de les traiter
comme des adultes
madame monsieur bonsoir du nouveau donc
dans la sphère de la profanation du
cimetière de carpentras quatre suspects
ont été interpellés dont deux seraient
passés aux aveux
certaines des personnes interpellées
seraient proches du pfn le parti
nationaliste français et européens un
groupuscule d'extrême droite en quête
valérie et dermit allemand nico si le
festival d'avignon se termine cette
semaine mais le coup de théâtre est venu
de l'hôtel de police dans ses locaux les
enquêteurs de la pj garde à vue quatre
personnes soupçonnées d'être impliquées
dans la profanation du cimetière juif de
carpentras intervenue il ya six ans six
ans que madeleine géré monde se bat avec
ténacité pour que l'on sache enfin qui a
exhumé le corps de son mari aussi à la
nouvelle des arrestations at elle du mal
à cacher son réconfort
je suis très contente darmon malheur je
suis très content car il a fallu plus de
six ans pour trouver les coupables et
j'espère qu'ils vont être punis
sévèrement punis à l'origine de ce coup
de filet le travail des rg d'avignon qui
aurait localisé dans cette résidence
universitaire l'un des profanateurs
présumés il aurait passé des aveux
précis et circonstanciés et semble issue
au moins partiellement du milieu skins
au départ c'était une mode il y avait
dix skinheads d'extrême droite y avait
des skinheads d'extrême gauche il ne
reste toujours et puis au fil des années
cette mouvance s'est politisée ne reste
plus aujourd'hui sur le devant de la
scène que les éléments les plus radicaux
qui sont très nettement des adeptes de
l'idéologie
néo nazis une cinquième personne un
jeune homme aurait été arrêté par la
gendarmerie dans les pyrénées orientales
il est lui aussi entendu à l'heure
actuelle à avignon aucun de ces jeunes
ne semblent originaire de carpentras
ville on est tout à la fois surpris et
soulagé de ce nouveau rebondissement les
faits honda 10 remonte au 10 mai 81 10
34 sépulture avait alors été mise à sac
et le corps d'un homme exhumés depuis
plus de six ans l' enquête est allé d'un
passant fou rebondissements rappelle
signé michael darmon et valérie ermite
nous sommes le 10 mai 1990 et ce que
vont découvrir deux femmes dans le
cimetière juif de carpentras va
bouleverser la france entière nous
creusons sûreté le cercueil placé le
cercueil ils ont sorti le morne où l'on
déshabille et deux sur l'assaut ils ont
exposé sur un ton pierre joxe alors
ministre de l'intérieur se rend
immédiatement sur les lieux lui a déjà
son idée sur les coupable se dénonce
donc le racisme l'antisémitisme
l'intolérance la sphère devient alors
une affaire d'état le 14 mai à paris
toute la classe politique manifeste côte
à côte et dénonce les idées de l'extrême
droite le front national est montré du
doigt
[Applaudissements]
l'enquète s'emballe des centaines
d'arrestations ont eu lieu y compris
dans les milieux skin du sud de la
france mais ces auditions ne donneront
rien l'enquêté est au point mort
jusqu'à l'été 1995
geci foulon une jeune carpentrassienne
croit savoir que les profanateurs sont
des jeunes fils de notables de la ville
comment l'avez-vous su par une amie d'un
profanateurs qu'est ce que vous en
raconter des consulteurs ki zerbo
le nouveau procureur voudrait croire à
cette piste et annonce des mises en
examen rapide
les enquêteurs vont faire en sorte de
d'explorer ces nouvelles pistes jusqu'à
ce que nous découvrions la vérité et
nous découvrirons la vérité à carpentras
tout le monde croit connaître les
auteurs de la profanation
tout le monde y compris jean marie le
pen qui demande aux novembre dans la
ville
les excuses publiques de la part de
l'ancien gouvernement socialiste
[Musique]
pourtant l'enquêté s'enlise le climat
devient assez détestable
au point que pour la bonne
administration de la justice le tribunal
de carpentras et le juge d'instruction
sylvie motte sont dessaisi du dossier au
profit du tribunal de marseille
aujourd'hui plus de six ans après la
profanation retour à la case départ la
piste d'extrême droite deux mouvances
ont évoqué le parti nationaliste
français et européens
un mouvement néonazi et le groupe skin
charlemagne tous deux réputés pour leur
extrémisme et leur violence
4 ancien skinhead comparaissent depuis
ce matin devant le tribunal
correctionnel de marseille
ils ont reconnu être les auteurs de la
profanation du cimetière juif de
carpentras était temps en 1990 valérie
arbitres
philippe josse la madeleine germain
avait 80 ans lorsque la tombe de son
mari félix fut profanée et son corps
exhumés cela fait maintenant presque
sept ans que madeleine germond attend ce
moment là
tout à l'heure j'étais angoissé
maintenant ça va mieux vous appréhendez
les bosses non
allez voir des prévenus madeleine
germain ne verra que leur dos jean sweat
shirt baskets
seule leur coupe de cheveux encore très
courte pour trois d'entre eux rappelle
ce qu'ils furent des skinheads
c'est yannick garnier qui le premier a
pris la parole tout comme ce 31 juillet
1996 lorsqu'il s'était présenté
spontanément à la police pour se
dénoncer
nous formions un groupe dit il fasciné
par l'ordre établi l'apologie de la race
blanche
l'antisémitisme et la haine de
l'étranger oui nous admirions à la
politique d'adolphe hitler mais j'ai
complètement changé ajoute-t-il
à l'époque j'étais embrigader lorsque le
président lui a posé la question de
savoir ce qu'était le troisième reich il
a répondu c'est le système qui a été
créée par le point de suspension par
adolf hitler
j'ai le sentiment que le führer est
resté dans son esprit quelque part avec
le bon en fait la seule sincérité qui
baissent et les tilleuls faire table
rase du passé comme l'a dit le président
est de pouvoir offrir à sa future
famille un visage plus respectable
yannick garnier dit pourtant être fiers
aujourd'hui fière d'avoir parlé fier
d'avoir des regrets et aux autres jeunes
qui seraient un jour tenté de faire
comme lui il ya sept ans je leur dirai
répond-t-il il faut qu'il revienne dans
le monde des vivants de les garder en
sus pour nous ce procès alors dominique
une particularité
ce procès intervient tout de même sept
ans après les faits oui ce qui fait
qu'on navigue aujourd'hui entre des
autoportraits de nazillons repentis des
prises de conscience à voix haute et ne
hier il se déclare tolérant j'était un
lâche influençable le front national a
parasité mes pensées déclare l'un des
prévenus
il ya donc une volonté de minimiser une
volonté aussi d'assumer un acte qui au
moment des fêtes est considérée pour eux
je cite une grosse bêtise
donc effectivement le temps joue pour
eux il leur permet de se présenter
aujourd'hui sous un jour un peu plus
humain on n'aime rien que ça ne soit pas
simplement un système de défense or
dominique on se souvient des
conséquences médiatiques est énorme de
ceux de 7,7 à fermer qu'encourent les
est ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui jugés
quelles sont les peines encourues pour
ce type de délit oui vous l'avez dit la
profanation carpentras et l émotion le
dégoût d'une communauté d'une classe
politique de tout un peuple c'est aussi
six ans de dérapage judiciaire
médiatique
c'est aussi six ans de rumeurs de
manipulations et bien la réponse
aujourd'hui judiciaire semble en
décalage par rapport à cette émotion et
ceux des goûts puisque le code pénal ne
prévoit une peine maximum de deux ans de
prison ce qui veut dire aussi que dans
tous les cas de figure les prévenus
condamnés à moins qu'ils soient
évidemment par l'axé mais en cas de
condamnation il serait de toute façon
libérée dans l'année qui vient à
marseille au procès des quatre jeunes
auteurs de la profanation du cimetière
juif de carpentras suite des débats
aujourd'hui avec notamment la déposition
du rabbin sitruk et cet après-midi
l'exposé des faits par les accusés
eux-mêmes dominique verdeilhan vallée m
le juge sylvie motte n'a jamais accepté
d'être dessaisi du dossier
elle a dû faire face aux rumeurs aux
manipulations aux pressions médiatiques
toutes les pistes ont été vérifiés dit
aline n'était pas question pour moi de
fermer le dossier
mais à la barre sylvie mode se retient
pour ce magistrat visiblement blessé ce
n'est ni le lieu ni l'heure des
règlements de compte
le procès est ailleurs quand les quatre
prévenus mal à l'aise détail la
profanation
on passe de l'horreur à l'immonde
exhumation simulacre d'emballement
tentative de décapitation cette nuit là
ils n'ont éprouvé qu'une seule répulsion
l'odeur du cadavre courageuse digne
madame germond apostrophe les quatre
prévenus vous êtes des criminels vous
m'avez tué je vais souffrir jusqu'à ma
mort
si au moins vous pouviez me dire
pourquoi sol garnier celui qui a avoué
se lève
je regrette tout ce que j'ai fait
c'était de l'antisémitisme je voulais
vous demander pardon
ça m'a fait du bien de les voir et de
nous parler m'a bien réserver il a
compris pourquoi il a fait ça je lui ai
demandé pourquoi mais pourquoi alors ce
soir résonnent encore les mots du grand
rabbin joseph sitruk ils n'ont tué
personne
ils ont fait tout le monde le pardon ne
sera effectif que lorsqu'ils auront
compris ce qu'ils ont fait mais ce soir
force est de constater que pour trois
des profanateurs le mot pardon
n'appartient pas à leur vocabulaire
autre procès à marseille cette fois ci
dans la sphère des profanateurs de
carpentras le grand rabbin de france
joseph sitruk est intervenu au deuxième
jour de ce procès il n'est pas venu
réclamer une sanction mais il a souhaité
que ces jeunes gens reçoivent une leçon
valérie ermite dominique verdeilhan à
d'autres ici pas de paroles de
profanateurs ce matin tous ont écouté le
grand rabbin de france dans le
témoignage à l'audience fut hautement
symbolique
je veux surtout dire que c'est pas le
procès de la communauté c'est le procès
de la france qui est important c'est en
fait l'humanité que les pressions je
t'aime beaucoup plus que qu'un homme
joseph sitruk a stigmatisé la lâcheté du
geste
c'est un cri de révolte que je pousse au
nom de ceux qui ne peuvent plus le faire
c'est plus qu'une communauté qui a été
insulté c'est la france c'est un pays
tout entier qu'il faut réhabiliter et
c'est à l'humanité qu'il faut redonner
de l'espérance
quelque part ils vont grandir avec le
mépris
de l'autre ils vont grandir avec la
haine et la haine il faut savoir
l'extirper du coeur lexie près du coeur
il faut peut-être les aider il faut les
aider par une leçon pour les aider par
un enseignement de surtout dire que pour
moi l'histoire c'est pas seulement les
faits c'est les leçons que l'on repère
si beaucoup plus qu'une sanction que
j'attends dit il au tribunal
c'est une leçon et si elle est comprise
tout le monde aura gagné puis il
s'adresse aux profanateurs c'est vrai
vous n'avait tué personne mais
finalement vous avez tué tout le monde
à marseille les profanateurs du
cimetière juif de carpentras ont entendu
aujourd'hui les différents avocats de la
partie civile les mettre en accusation
mais aussi ceux qui par leur discours
ont inspiré leur geste reportage
dominique verdeilhan philippe jaffelin
front commun du côté des avocats des
victimes ce n'est plus le procès de
quatre profanateurs mais celui d'un
cinquième homme jean marie le pen
le procès d'une idéologie celle de
l'extrême droite les prévenus l'ont
admis certes le troisième reich les
fascinait mais le discours du front
national les a séduit presque conforté
dans la haine de l'autre
vous êtes les rejetons de le pen le
boutiquier de l'immonde lance un premier
avocat
vous êtes les instruments des partis
fascistes enchaîne un second vous êtes
passés de la théorie à la pratique est
incontestablement c'est la génération le
pen sont ceux qui à un moment donné
baignant dans ce discours
influencé par celui ci pensons que l'on
peut tout dire si on peut tout dire on
peut tout faire
devant le risque d'une banalisation du
discours devant la crainte de voir
l'histoire se répétait les avocats des
parties civiles veulent donner à ce
procès une valeur pédagogique
on a indiqué à ces gens que le juif
était différent que le gif était
nuisible pour la société française
et c'est ce qui les a motivés et c'est
la raison pour laquelle ce procès doit
être pédagogique pour montrer que cela
n'est que pas days à la veille des
réquisitions les caps profanateurs sont
passés au second plan alors soulignant
le côté dérisoire de la peine encourue
deux ans de prison au maximum
les victimes ne parlent plus de
sanctions mais de leçon
ce qu'il faut autant
retenir de l'actualité aujourd'hui en
france et à l'étranger en commençant par
le jugement dans la sphère de carpentras
sept ans après la profanation du
cimetière juif
quatre hommes ont été condamnés à de la
prison ferme karine shana lionel cottu
les profanateurs n'ont exprimé aucune
émotion à l'annoncé du jugement le
tribunal a suivi les réquisitions deux
ans de prison ferme pour patrick la rue
negro et olivier saint bris en revanche
il a alourdi de 18 à 20 mois de prison
la peine de yannick garnier bertrand
nouveau
ce jugement est important parce qu'elle
comprend plus de sanctions qui est une
sanction républicaine sur des faits qui
sont des faits il humain et puis parce
que c'est un jugement c'est une décision
qui fera date
de son côté madeleine jammu et rester
chez elles ne voulant pas s'infliger une
épreuve supplémentaire aujourd'hui ce
qu'elle veut c'est oublié j'aime bien
ces eaux là surtout pour ceux que j'ai
eus comme on raconte passe à carpentras
[Musique]
l'église épilogue judiciaire de la
sphère de la profanation de cimetière
juif de carpentras les quatre skinheads
ont été condamnés à des peines de 20 à
24 mois de prison ferme
reportage valérie ermite et reed
georgeault puis que quelques minutes et
madeleine germans connaîtra les pilotes
judiciaire de la profanation de la tombe
de son mari à un mois près c'était il ya
cette envie ça finisse je n'en peux plus
aussi fatigué j'en ai assez
et je voudrais quitter carpentras là où
l'ego est ce que ces deux ans de prison
avec ce qu'ils ont pu je comprends que
quand on regardait la preuve est la
justice française ouvre est ce que vous
auriez préféré
ben je sais pas évidemment je ne sais
plus rien maurane du fort louis
elle ne sait plus très bien quoi penser
madeleine germond à la fois déçu tout en
ne regrettant pas le pardon qu'elle leur
a accordé au même moment au palais de
justice de marseille le jugement vient
de tomber deux ans le maximum pour faire
briller la au negro les plus déterminés
ce qui selon le tribunal semble encore
inspiré par les relents de leur pensée
20 mois pour garnier nouveau ceux qui
ont demandé pardon qu'on a châtié avec
cette peine de deux ans d'emprisonnement
les mains qui ont agi il espère que ce
procès aura un enseignement pour les
têtes qui pense c'est à dire ceux qui
véhiculent une idéologie pareil à
carpentras cette fois le maire respire
la ville pourra peut-être enfin tourner
la page
l'image de thermalright salle il faut
bien le dire et on était un point noir
sur la carte
donc j'espère qu'aujourd'hui les gens
les français verront deuil la fin donne
à nouveau notre ville madeleine elle a
pardonné mais n'a rien oublié
elle voudrait maintenant quitté la ville
mais le pourra t-elle vraiment
[Musique]